hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to tattletale now this is a
game about horrible Furby like
monstrosities trying to kill you in one
way or another I have no idea what this
game is about specifically but all I
know is that from the cover art it's
horrible Furby monstrosity is trying to
kill you and that's no good
that is no bueno okay open your
Christmas present early I don't want to
do that I want to be a good boy wanna be
a good boy oh boy I'm not a good boy am
i oh man am i a child is that why
everything looks horrible oh god why do
I have that deal with it okay I'm I'm me
me at least I know I'm a me me young
brat oh boy oh boy
hold shift of run careful it makes noise
what do I gotta do I gotta worry about
waking up my momma do I gotta worry
about waking up anybody at home oh
that's so cool what's the yellow icon on
the top right to see when you're making
noise oh that's so cool oh that's so
cool oh this is weird
why does why do my parents just have a
sitting room why do they just sit in the
unfinished basement by themselves that
doesn't make any sense at all what am I
looking for I mean I know I'm looking
for my presents but oh okay over here
yes okay
okay okay he really eats grabbed some
food from the upstairs fridge that's not
good tattletale how about you shut up
shut up I need to get upstairs
brushable hair used the brush in the
living room to clean tattletale to do
this why is this a necessity Oh what did
you say you tired
oh god this is creepy
ah be tired
it is dark how do you know that you
should be tired okay
caboose cute why did I do that what did
I do that
Oh what do I feel so bad about it
[ __ ] was that the [ __ ] you said okay
okay alright I'm not gonna listen to the
monstrous
don't answer the pain hello
well we're good to hear from you buddy
glad you're doing well I'm just gonna go
[ __ ] off and cook him bad Oh
God sent my parents room oh no this is
outside why is the front door open dad
what's goin on I closed my door
no alrighty then okay oh why was that so
creepy oh geez investigate the clunking
noise oh okay alright are my parents
just removed from this equation
that is my parents you know wrestling
[ __ ] dude oh of course
oh the clunking is in the basement the
[ __ ] is going on down there is that mr.
tattletale
it sounds like it might be a laundry
machine can't go there the hidden room
oh it is Oh
[Music]
remember there being a Vaz up there but
yeah that is you all right that is a
hundred percent you yeah I don't know
where there'd be another vase okay
alright let's play a game okay okay you
barely know me you don't know if you
love me okay alright then playing are we
gonna break it wrapped handle tale back
up but what the [ __ ] was up there the
[ __ ] is up there oh it's to cellar door
some events and creatures make your
flash okay alright go to bed please
nothing Bad's gonna happen right nothing
Bad's gonna happen on the way back right
why didn't I notice these eggs before
french fry tonic number six okay I'm not
gonna find all the eggs that's for sure
because I already missed some on the
first night
hello yellow okay you know you keep
banging I'm just gonna go to bed now oh
go to bed I have enough of this
nightmare land I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on last night oh the [ __ ]
is that noise the grinding noise oh oh
that's what you'd call grinding okay I
said you call it the wails of the Damned
all of my nightmares congregating into
one area
[Music]
okay you know what Bob it's okay I'll
I'll investigate it all by own how could
I miss them your hair beautiful it's
like it's a [ __ ] trail
what the [ __ ] is that locust set in de
mama
oh it's mama tattletale the children not
that mama would never find them as long
as she couldn't see them
[Music]
but mama didn't kill me here in the
show-me the pitter-patter of their
little feet let mama write to them
turn the page
[Music]
are you talking about my mom or your
mama your mama is good go downstairs now
where the hell is Vince I don't know
what it's gonna mean when I bring you to
mama I don't know why I need to bring
you to Volvo
yeah sure is isn't it good did the
distant noise even mean anything
what is the noise
be fired
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you are I don't know
how you keep coming out of your box but
you get the flips begin cleanup
tattletales mess oh the one he made
upstairs oh okay okay alright it's not
so bad
just got to get it done apparently I
don't even need to worry about anything
hearing me or at least not dying
[Music]
he's a better mother than ever me oh man
oh [ __ ] man oh [ __ ] terrifying god
damn it okay all right okay all right
okay all right we're gonna pause we're
gonna pause just hold on
investigate the chattering coming oh
we're gonna pause we're just gonna pause
we're gonna pause this we're gonna put
it on pause continue funny games oh boy
okay so this is [ __ ] its [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] oh my god
this so [ __ ] scary why why is that
scary why pitties away that's the first
part of tattletale I'll I'll definitely
be more of this game but oh my god I
don't know if I can do either way thank
you everybody so much for watching you
can play this game through Steam I'll
put a link down in the description let
me know what you thought of it it's holy
[ __ ]
so thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]